Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, ich könnte dir Dinge erzählen.
Tim, ich rufe dich hiermit zur Verschlüsselung auf.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Ausgabe Nummer 509 vom 12.
Dezember 2024.
Wir nähern uns dem Jahresende.
Genau. Gerüchte sagen, ich hätte letztes Mal nicht gesagt, was das Datum ist.
Geschweige denn, was die Sendungsnummer ist. Das kann natürlich nicht sein,
weil sowas vergesse ich ja nie.
Ja, fast Weihnachten, Tim, oder? Jetzt haben wir dieses Jahr endlich geschafft.
Ja, ich hoffe du hast schon meine Geschenke eingepackt.
Das kommt noch, aber ich habe alle besorgt, fast alle.
Hervorragend, das finde ich gut. Ja, genau.
Es gab jetzt nicht so viel Feedback zur letzten Sendung und von daher kann man
eigentlich auch gleich loslegen, würde ich fast sagen.
Warum rufst du mich denn zur Verschlüsselung auf?
Wir bräuchten einen Ironie-Jingle für diesen.
Podcast und auf jeden Fall auch für die nächste Meldung Das ist eine Ironie
Das ist eine gute Idee Ich frage mich nur, wie wie könnte ein Ironie-Jingle sein Wir.
Lassen das jetzt einfach mal so stehen.
Das haben wir ja in Jahren Ich meine, Internet Wie lange missverstehen sich
die Leute jetzt schon im Prinzip seit den 80er Jahren Ja, das klappt länger,
Kaum, dass es Mailinglisten und Foren gab So News Foren,
Missverständnisse. Leute blöcken sich voll und es war einfach,
eigentlich war schon alles abzusehen in den 90ern, worauf es hinausläuft.
Aber wir wollten es ja nicht sehen.
Wir wollten ja an eine gloriose Zukunft glauben.
Und immer war dieses Thema mit, wie markieren wir denn eigentlich Ironie,
damit wir uns nicht permanent an den Hals gehen.
Und es gab tatsächlich Vorschläge für so Ironie, Emojis und sowas.
Es hat sich nichts durchgesetzt.
Also ich finde den Emoji, der die Augen nach oben rollt, der ist schon sehr
hilfreich in vielen Situationen.
Ja, ist, aber ist das Ironie?
Ja, ich glaube, wir vertrauen hier auf Kreativität unserer Hörer hin.
Es ist die Reaktion vielleicht auf sowas. Also jetzt kommt auf jeden Fall,
ein Abschnitt in der Sendung, den man sehr gut mit einem Rolling Eyes Emoji
kommentieren könnte, aber ich glaube nicht, dass damit ausreichend eingeführt
wäre. Naja, nur so nebenbei ein Gedanke.
Als Anthropologe sage ich dir, Kultur ist stetig wandelnd und deswegen, ja, bleibt spannend.
Wieso? Ironie? Worum geht's? US-Geheimdienste rufen zur Verschlüsselung auf.
Und das ist eine ehrliche Meldung, dass FBI und die amerikanische Cyber-Sicherheitsbehörde
CISA haben nämlich eindringlich dazu aufgerufen, Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte
Messenger zu verwenden, also sowas wie Signal.
Hintergrund dieses Aufrufs sind Angriffe auf US-Mobilfunknetze,
die angeblich von chinesischen Hackergruppen ausgehen.
Und dabei wurden nicht nur massiv Metadaten über diese Netze abgegriffen,
sondern auch Inhaltsdaten von Personen aus dem US-Politikbetrieb,
darunter Donald Trump und Kamala Harris.
Besonders brisant jetzt und deswegen finde ich jetzt auch wirklich diesen Ironie-Jungel verdient,
die chinesischen Hacker haben sich dabei Law-Enforcement-Schnittstellen bedient,
also jene Hintertüren an bewusst eingebaute Sicherheitslücken,
vor denen wir immer gewarnt haben, dass die eben nicht nur für die Guten sind,
sondern wenn du eine Hintertüre einbaust, dann kann da jeder durchgehen,
der weiß, wie er da rankommt.
Und genauso ist es jetzt hier auch passiert.
Und das FBI insbesondere ist dafür bekannt, sich gegen Verschlüsselungen auszusprechen.
Wir erinnern uns an den Streit mit Apple rund um das iPhone des San Bernardino-Attentäters
und man könnte das jetzt positiv als Selbsterkenntnis bewerten oder vielleicht
auch ein bisschen als Selbstaufgabe, weil,
wie das jetzt auch schon öfter von der politischen Community gesagt wurde,
die Gefahren halt immer größer werden und wir in Sicherheit investieren müssen
und Verschlüsselung ist Teil von Sicherheit.
Und gerade in Bezug auf den Zugriff auf Metadaten ist auch nochmal zu erwähnen,
dass die Vorratsdatenspeicherung solche Situationen nur schlimmer macht, weil je mehr Daten,
Daten ein Mobilfunkbetreiber hat und speichert und speichern muss laut Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
umso mehr kann NARA natürlich dann auch wegkommen.
Deswegen ist Vorratsdatenspeicherung eine dumme und gefährliche Idee.
Ja, wenn erstmal der Weizen im Lager liegt, dann sind die Mäuse nicht weit.
Da kannst du noch so viel Kotzen hinterher schicken.
Aber der FBI-Direktor ist ja eh heute angekündigt, dass er zurücktreten wird
und vorauseilend gehorsam.
Weil er gegen so ein Bozo ersetzt wird. Oh Mann ey, das wird wirklich jetzt eine wilde Reise.
Ey, wir müssen noch nicht über Trump reden. Wir können noch ein paar Wochen,
machen wir dann am Kongress. Auch zu dem kommen wir noch, aber zuerst,
das wäre fast eine gute Nachricht.
Es ist aber auch eine Schlagzeile.
Ich habe die gegoogelt und die haben wir wirklich, die haben ganz viele schon
mehrmals genau in dem Wortlaut verwendet, nämlich Chatkontrolle vorerst gestoppt.
Was ist passiert? Heute tagt der EU-Ministerrat,
das sind die JustizministerInnen der EU-Mitgliedstaaten der 27 und da steht
auch wieder mal die Chatkontrolle auf der Tagesordnung,
aber die Gefahr scheint schon gebannt, weil die ungarische Ratspräsidentschaft
hat es wirklich jetzt x-mal probiert, hier einen Text durchzuboxen.
Wir stehen ja in diesem Prozess, wo das Parlament abgestimmt hat,
die haben seine Textversion.
Aber der Rat ist sich immer noch nicht einig, wie sie zu diesem Gesetz stehen.
Und ohne diese Einigung kann es keine gemeinsamen Verhandlungen mit dem Parlament geben.
Und diese Einigung wird es auch unter der ungarischen Ratspräsidentschaft nicht
mehr geben. Die läuft ja mit Jahresende ab.
Und die hat es nicht geschafft, einen Kompromiss zu erzielen.
Politico spricht heute auch davon, dass dieser Ministerrat nur ein Name-and-Shame-Meeting
wird, aber dass man sich nicht einig wird, weil unter anderem,
und hier ist ein Dank ausgesprochen, Deutschland, Österreich,
Slowenien, Tschechien,
die Niederlande und andere Staaten sich einfach querlegen.
Also da scheint auch die gute Arbeit von Leuten wie Khaleesi und Elie Jakubowski
von Edrey und vielen, vielen anderen geholfen haben, dass man diesen Kompromiss verhindern konnte.
Und es ist auch so der Zeitpunkt, vielleicht mal darüber nachzudenken,
ob das nicht schon die Definition von Wahnsinn ist, weil so einen Anlauf,
das zu verabschieden, den gab es jetzt schon, seit die Chatkontrolle vorgelegt wurde am 11.
Mai 2022, von Frankreich, Tschechien, Schweden, Spanien, Belgien und jetzt Ungarn.
Also diese Länder hatten alle schon die Ratspräsidentschaft inne und haben verhandelt,
teils wirklich mit massivem Ressourceneinsatz und alle sind sie gescheitert.
Als nächstes kommt jetzt Polen mit Jänner dran. Wir haben auch wieder die halbjährliche
Ratspräsidentschaft, die ja immer rotiert zwischen den Staaten.
Ach Gott sei Dank ist jetzt bald vorbei mit Ungarn, okay.
Ja, ja. Aber das heißt dieses Thema vorläufig gute Nachrichten.
Es wird aber auf jeden Fall weiter, wir verlinken auch schon einen Brief,
den wir diese Woche veröffentlicht haben mit vielen anderen NGOs zu der sogenannten
Going Dark Arbeitsgruppe.
Hat auch was mit Verschlüsselung zu tun, das ist ja was die SicherheitspolitikerInnen
immer sagen und die Polizisten auch.
Wenn wir verschlüsseln, dann heißt das, die Polizei ist Going Dark,
sieht nichts mehr und dagegen muss man was tun.
Verschlüsselung ist ja böse und genau deswegen gibt es jetzt diesen offenen
Brief, da nochmal darauf hinzuweisen, dass die Vorschläge dieser Going Dark
Arbeitsgruppe, die heißt wirklich so,
halt genau die falsche Richtung vorgehen, nämlich das wäre ein Angriff auf Verschlüsselung,
das wäre mehr Überwachung und da sind wir dagegen.
Alright,
So und das ist eine Meldung von der habe ich noch gar nichts gehört,
das ist ja krass, also jetzt wo Ungarn sozusagen Schluss mit seiner,
Ratspräsidentschaft macht, haben Sie sich auf andere Aktivitäten umgelegt oder was?
Also die Meldung ist, dass aufgrund einer gemeinsamen investigativen Recherche
vom ungarischen Medium Direkt 36 und der belgischen Tageszeitung The Ditched,
Ich versuche das richtig auszusprechen.
Ist es so, dass der.
Ungarische Zeit heißt das und die Zeit sozusagen war vollendisch.
Ah, okay, danke.
Nicht, dass ich vollendisch kann, aber ich schlage da mit Sicherheit nochmal nach.
Also, ungarische Geheimdienste hacken EU-Beamte. Und zwar im großen Stil.
Es dürfte so sein, dass der ungarische Geheimdienst aufgrund dieser Medien,
wirklich EU-Beamte mit ihren Arbeitslaptops gehackt hat, teilweise in Hotelzimmer
eingebrochen ist, Telefongespräche abgehört hat.
Es dürfte hier eine eigene Abteilung geben innerhalb des ungarischen Geheimdienstes,
die sich nur mit dem Beschatten und Informationsbeschaffen rund um EU-Beamte kümmert.
Insbesondere gibt es eine EU-Behörde, die hier im Fokus steht, Tim.
Du darfst raten, welche EU-Behörde wird den Ungarn besonders unter den Nägeln brennen?
Und was mit Korruption?
Ja, genau.
Olaf, die Antikorruptionsbehörde, Olaf lieber Name eigentlich,
die haben sich nämlich Orbans Schwiegersohn angeschaut.
Und der ist ins Visier gekommen, weil seine Firma so sehr viele öffentliche
Ausschreibungen gewonnen hat und das hat dann ein paar Fragen aufgeworfen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein super Geschäftsmann.
Absolut, ja. Und das viele Steuergeld, was in seine Taschen floss,
hat dann eben Olaf, die Antikorruptionsbehörde, auf den Teppich gebracht und
die sind jetzt sehr akribisch natürlich davor gegangen,
haben jetzt in ihrem Statement aufgrund dieser Medienberichte nichts bestätigt,
aber schon gesagt, es ist wichtig, dass EU-Behörden ihre Arbeit machen können.
Es zeigt glaube ich einfach wie schlimm es um die Rechtsstaatlichkeit in Ungarn
und in Europa bestellt ist, wenn einfach vor allem eben die Leute,
die wahrscheinlich mit sehr viel Mut gegen Korruption vorgehen,
die ja eh in Ungarn nicht mehr aus Ungarn kommen sondern EU-Behörden sind,
mit einem eingeschränkten Mandat, aber wenn es um EU-Geld geht,
können die halt hinschauen und die dann mit Geheimdienstmethoden zu bespitzeln,
das ist schon russisches Niveau.
Ja, also ich meine, dass er russisches Niveau hat, das ist schon seit längerem
relativ klar geworden, aber das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich knallhart.
Ich meine, ich frage mich halt ehrlich gesagt auch wirklich,
wie lange die EU dieses Spiel noch mitspielt.
Ich meine, es ist natürlich schon ein Machtkampf und es wurde ja auch schon
gerade im Ukraine-Krieg in der Auseinandersetzung da drum die Daumenschrauben
zumindest schon mal ein paar,
Millimeter angezogen und Das hat ja auch eine Reaktion gezeigt,
aber die nächste Blockade steht ja im Prinzip immer wieder gleich vor der Tür,
speziell jetzt, wo er im Oberwasser meint zu haben,
dadurch, dass Trump an die Macht gekommen ist, was natürlich jetzt auch nur
so indirekt eine Rolle spielt für die EU,
aber den muss man schon wirklich kräftig beiseite räumen, wenn man da irgendwie mal Ruhe finden will.
Und ich verstehe immer nicht so richtig, warum die EU da so lange braucht, dagegen vorzugehen.
Also im Prinzip hat, ich meine, eigentlich...
Eigentlich müsste Ungarn austreten, weil sie einfach die Kriterien derzeit überhaupt
gar nicht mehr erfüllen.
Das ist natürlich ein langer Weg und im Prinzip ist das ja auch eine der Geburtsschwächen
der EU, dass es sozusagen fürs Rausschmeißen überhaupt gar keine Regeln gibt.
Man ist nie davon ausgegangen, dass irgendjemand, der da mal drin ist,
auch wieder rausgehen könnte oder müsste und insofern muss man halt schauen,
wie man die Sanktionsmittel, die halt da sind, auch wirklich effektiv einsetzt.
Natürlich ist klar, man hat viel Verflechtung und so weiter und das ist jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt das, was man will.
Man will ja nicht, dass Ungarn raus ist, sondern man will halt einfach darauf hinwirken,
dass die da mal wieder auf die Rechtsspur, also nicht auf die rechtsstaatliche Spur kommen.
Und ja, da könnte ehrlich gesagt meiner Auffassung nach noch ein bisschen mehr
passieren, weil wir haben ja gesehen, schon mit Polen, wie es die Sachen verzögert.
Jetzt ist die Slowakei auch schon wieder, macht schon wieder ein paar Umdrehungen
und in Österreich will ich gerne erst anfangen, also es bleibt schwierig.
Ja, ich meine, man kann ja auch Mitgliedstaaten der EU das Stimmrecht im Rat entziehen.
Das wäre auch noch so eine Option. Das ist auch kein einfacher Prozess.
Jetzt wo Polen wieder eingeschwenkt ist, ist die Frage, hätte man da jetzt die
anderen 26 bereit so einen Schritt zu setzen.
Anlasspunkte gibt es genug. Aber natürlich wird Orban immer noch rufiert.
Er war auch in Österreich der erste Gast bei unserem neuen FPÖ-Parlamentspräsidenten
mit so fast wie einem Mini-Staatsbesuch.
Mit Trump wird er auch einen starken Fürsprecher haben. Ich meine,
und man darf nicht vergessen, dass von der Leyen da auch, jetzt sind eher so
Rumors, aber dass es da auch Verbindungen gibt und sie dem Ganzen gar nicht
so abgeneigt ist, so Keeping the Peace mäßig.
Aber ja, wer weiß, ob nicht vielleicht auch Orban innenpolitisch mal mehr unter Druck kommt.
Er kommt ja schon unter Druck. Also es gibt ja mittlerweile eine relativ starke
Figur, die politisch gerade aufsteigt.
So ein ehemaliges Parteimitglied, der im Rahmen der letzten Skandale sehr bekannt
und populär geworden ist, auch schon bei der EU-Wahl nennenswerte Fortschritte erzählt hat.
Das ist durchaus denkbar, aber man kann sich natürlich vorstellen,
dass eine nationale Wahl, wo es ums alles geht,
Orban dann natürlich auch wirklich maximale Maßnahmen ergreifen wird und ob
seine Macht so stark ist, das dann auch einfach durchzuboxen und die Wahl so weit zu beeinflussen,
dass er dann trotzdem wieder siegesreich davon sieht, das lässt sich derzeit
einfach noch überhaupt nicht absehen.
Naja, wir werden sehen und berichten.
Wir werden auch berichten über diesen Sprint-Pitch-Day, wo du gestern warst. Ich bin ganz gespannt.
Ich war bei der Jury-Sitzung am Tag davor.
Aber wir haben das Event angekündigt in der letzten Sendung und du bist da noch
wirklich hingegangen. Und ich bin total neugierig. Wie war das denn, Tim?
Ja, also worum geht es? Sprint ist ja die Bundesagentur für Sprunginnovation.
Was irgendwie eine lustige Wortschöpfung ist. Auf Englisch ist es dann,
finde ich, fast schon etwas klarer.
Da ist dann sozusagen von Disruptive, wie heißt das genau, Disruptive, wie nennen sie das?
Nicht Deep Innovation oder Leapfrogging?
Innovation, ja genau. Deep Innovation, Breakthrough Innovation.
Here we go. Das ist die offizielle Bezeichnung. Federal Agency for Breakthrough Innovation.
Also es geht hier darum, also die Bundesagentur ist vor ein paar Jahren gegründet
worden, wird geführt von Rafael Vigara de Laguna und ist ein super Typ,
ich hatte den auch mal im Forschung, heißt im Gespräch und der sorgt wirklich dafür, muss man sagen,
dass hier mal frischer Wind in den ganzen Behördenmythos einzieht.
Das Interessante an der Bundesagentur für Sprunginnovationen, also Sprint,
ist, dass sie eben als GmbH organisiert sind, obwohl sie quasi vom Staat beauftragt sind.
Das ist also sozusagen so eine bundeseigene GmbH und kann damit eben sehr viel
mehr wie eine Firma agieren, sehr viel freier agieren und wenn man halt auch
auf die Veranstaltung geht,
merkt man einfach relativ wenig von Staat.
Also es riecht einfach nicht nach Behörde. Also so gar nicht.
Und das war jetzt schon die zweite Veranstaltung, auf der ich war.
Die hatten irgendwie vor ein paar Monaten schon mal was ähnliches in Leipziges
und Leipzig und wenn du da halt so hingehst, also die ganze Atmo da vor Ort,
das war einfach mal alles so,
fühlte sich sehr viel mehr nach Republika und Startup-Party an,
als nach so einem Behördentreffen.
Ohne allerdings, ohne dieses total überdrehte Selbstbeweihräucherungsgedöns.
Also ich fand es wirklich sehr angenehm.
Sie haben jetzt quasi dieses Format der sogenannten Funke-Konferenzen da ausgerufen,
das war dann sozusagen unter diesem Label gestern.
Und worum es halt eigentlich ging, ist eben den nächsten Schritt zu gehen und
zu verkünden im Wettbewerb rund um die EU Wallet.
Das ist ja Teil dieser EU Digital Initiative und wem sage ich das?
Du bist ja auch in der Jury dieses Wettbewerbs mit drin.
Und kurz gesagt, in diesem Wettbewerb gibt es eben verschiedene Organisationen, Firmen,
die sich bewerben konnten, an diesem Wettbewerb teilzunehmen.
Und da gab es dann zwei Tracks, einen sogenannten Funded Track und einen Non-Funded Track.
Man konnte sich dann explizit für einen der beiden bewerben.
Das heißt, man sagt halt entweder so, ja wir wollen da teilnehmen,
aber wir müssen uns auch kein Geld geben, weil wir haben schon genug.
Da waren dann auch große Unternehmen dabei und dann eben kleinere Startups,
Unternehmen, die sagen so, können wir uns jetzt nicht leisten.
Hier da die Zeit für aufzuwenden mit euren krassen Deadlines und Anforderungen.
Wir brauchen auch ein bisschen Kohle. Und das war dann so 50-50 auch aufgeteilt.
Und soweit ich dann auch so Gespräche noch geführt habe gestern,
das war alles sehr interessant, waren die auch alle sehr zufrieden.
Also die waren sowohl zufrieden mit der finanziellen Ausstattung,
also das Funding selber meinten sie wäre einfach okay,
müsste man sich nicht groß verbiegen, wird man jetzt nicht mit reich mit,
aber man kriegt damit das sozusagen auch wirklich finanziert.
Also da wurde eine realistische Menge an Geld in die Hand genommen,
um die Sache wirklich voranzubringen und besonders wurde das eben auch alles
gelobt, wie dieser ganze Prozess von Sprint geführt wurde.
Ich habe wirklich sehr viele gefragt und es war eigentlich relativ klar,
dass dieser spezifische Ansatz, der dort gewählt wurde, da extrem geschätzt wurde.
Was war dieser spezifische Ansatz? Der spezifische Ansatz war.
Dass eben Sprint für diesen Wettbewerb diverse Experten aus unterschiedlichen
Bereichen herangeholt hat,
die also diesen Wettbewerb geleitet haben und auch für diese ganzen Teilnehmer
jederzeit ansprechbar waren.
Und nicht nur um irgendwie allgemeine Auskunft zu geben und um diesen Wettbewerb
als solchen durchzuführen, sondern die waren auch ganz real in die Entwicklung
der Software mit eingebunden bis hin zu,
dass die selber sich den Source-Code angeschaut haben, der da entwickelt wurde,
das ist ja alles Open-Source.
Und da konkret Vorschläge und Hinweise gegeben haben. Also das ist schon so
eine Art und Weise des Involvements, das kennt man halt nicht.
Normalerweise heißt es so eine Aufschreibung, da gibt es dann irgendwelche Konsortien.
Ja, hier habt ihr Kohle, macht mal, wir treffen uns acht Monaten wieder.
Und dann so, ja, die Hälfte haben wir fertig.
Keiner weiß genau, was da ist. Dann gibt es irgendwie ein paar langweilige Demos.
Keiner hat das richtig jemals getestet. Und dann kennen wir das ja,
dann wird die Software auf den Markt geworfen,
dann bricht irgendwie alles zusammen, dann kostet es nochmal das Doppelte,
bis da überhaupt irgendwas funktioniert und wenn man sich das mal anschaut,
wie das alles aussieht, dann kommt einem das kalte Kotzen das ist ja so der
normale Weg, wie das so läuft und das ist ja einfach komplett anders weil es
hier einfach komplett offen ist vollkommen egal mit was für einer,
Organisationsform man ist, also es gab halt Companies es gab irgendwelche losen Gruppen, die,
was weiß ich so für europäische Forschungsinstitute stehen und Garni,
also diese Also www.wallet zum Beispiel,
das sind einfach irgendwelche Leute, die auch querverteilt über den Planeten
wohnen und dann halt so open source mäßig zusammenarbeiten und die dann,
als sie erstmal den Vertrag unterschreiben sollten, das Problem hatten,
dass sie überhaupt gar keine Legal Entity hatten, mit der sie da irgendwie.
Die haben sie jetzt, die haben jetzt eine gemeinnützige Stiftung gegründet.
Genau, also man muss aber auch erst mal einen Weg finden sozusagen.
Aber das ist so die Bandbreite, die dort stattgefunden hat. Also das war ganz gut.
Und alles ist halt irgendwie offen und online und das ist schon alles ziemlich nice.
Genau, das Event selber war ganz cool. Also wie ich schon gesagt habe,
da ist ja einfach so ein komplett anderer Vibe, da das eben auch so viele internationale
Teilnehmer sind, die halt teilweise keinen Deutsch sprachen,
lief das auch alles auf Englisch.
Und ich muss sagen, ich habe auch nicht einen einzigen englischen Vortrag,
der zum Fremdschweben gewesen wäre gehört.
Also die konnten auch alle Englisch. Unglaublich.
Und es war noch nicht mal langweilig. Also es gab natürlich am Anfang so diese
übliche Begrüßung, aber das war dann halt so...
Auch völlig okay und alles nicht länger als es sein musste. Es gab dann etwas.
Ja, die Projekte haben sich vorgestellt, das haben sie dann irgendwie so ein
bisschen so battle-mäßig gemacht mit irgendwie, man muss dann sich jetzt hier
irgendwie selber nochmal pitchen.
Das fand ich ein bisschen langweilig, das wäre sicherlich besser gewesen,
man hätte einfach mal auch den sozusagen quasi so einen Kurzvortrag mit hier
ist unser Projekt, damit ihr mal wisst, was hier alles teilnimmt.
Das wäre ganz gut gewesen.
Und dann halt so diese üblichen Spaß ist, dass man mit so Mentimeter arbeitet,
wo die Leute dann so live Feedback geben können.
Das ist mir ja schon wieder fast ein bisschen zu verspielt für so Umfragen und Wordclouds.
Aber trotzdem, es wurde eben auch so ein bisschen drauf geachtet,
dass man auch so ein bisschen Fun hat auf der Veranstaltung.
Also es war jetzt einfach nicht nur so staubtrockene Informations runterrasseln,
sondern da herrschte einfach eine gute Stimmung und muss auch sagen,
sie haben auch da in dem Team ein paar Leute, die exzellente.
Kommunikatoren sind.
Also besonders ein eine Frau ist mir aufgefallen, die war einfach erschreckend
kompetent und irgendwie redegewandt und charmant auf, es war mega,
also es ist wirklich beeindruckend.
Naja, so lief dieser ganze Tag, es ging halt irgendwie von.
Von 10 bis in den Puppen. Es gab hervorragendes Essen.
Auch das ist ja irgendwie nicht normal. Ja und dann war das so aufgeteilt.
Erstmal halt die ganze Vorbereitungsteile und dann gab es einfach einen riesigen
Block, in dem erstmal gar nichts stattfindet, außer dass die Projekte sich nochmal
präsentieren konnten und man alle in einem großen Raum mit Essen war und die
ganze Zeit quatschen konnte.
Und da war also ein reges Gewusel und als das dann alles zu Ende war, gab es noch ein bisschen,
Nachprogramm und dann eben die Verkündung der Jury, weil ja letztlich an dem
Tag die Entscheidung fiel, welche der Projekte,
weiterkommen in die nächste Runde und weiter gefördert werden,
beziehungsweise im Wettbewerb teilnehmen dürfen und welche halt nicht mehr dabei
sind. Dann fiel dann eben die Hälfte bei raus.
Naja, ich habe dann die Zeit genutzt und habe halt mit den ganzen Projekten
geredet und habe vor allem eben auch mal versucht,
auch meine zuletzt in der letzten Sendung geäußerte Basiskritik Kritik nochmal
ein bisschen auf Realität abzuklappern und das war in der Hinsicht also sehr aufschlussreich.
Was war meine Kritik?
Also wir reden ja hier über eine Wallet, das heißt wir reden über eine App,
die das Ziel hat, so Dinge wie einen Personalausweis, Führerschein,
aber auch Krankenkassenkarten, theoretisch auch Payment, alles mögliche zu machen
und das soll natürlich irgendwie alles super sicher sein.
Und dafür gibt es ja dieses EU-DI, also diese EU-Vorgabe, diese Digital Initiative,
die dann halt das alles auch beschreibt auf technischen Ebene,
was sozusagen die Mindestanforderungen sind.
Das ist ja genau das, was jetzt quasi von diesen Wettbewerbsteilnehmern alles implementiert wird.
Und das soll natürlich auf Smartphones laufen, muss also vor allem primär auf
Smartphones laufen, ist aber jetzt auch so ausgelegt, dass es eben auch nicht
nur auf Smartphones laufen kann.
Aber da wir nicht in einer idealen Welt leben, ist halt die derzeitige Implementationsart so,
dass ich sage, warum ist denn das nicht anders, da komme ich auch gleich drauf. Was heißt das?
Das heißt, diese Wallets werden halt ihre Authentifizierung online überprüfen müssen. Warum?
Weil einfach es natürlich,
also die einzige sichere Methode Schlüssel auf dem Telefon abzulegen ist ja
die, wenn man so ein Secure Element hat, sprich ein Chip,
der quasi einen verborgenen, nicht für jede App erreichbaren oder auch nicht
durch Schadcode erreichbaren, einen Speicherbereich hat, so eine Vault,
so ein Tresor quasi im Prozessor,
mit dem man eben nur auf einen sehr dünnen definierten Kanal rein kommunizieren
kann und der einfach das Stehlen von Schlüsseln verhindert.
Das funktioniert soweit auch, kann man sagen. Technologie ist ja schon seit
einigen Jahren auf dem Markt und das ist wirklich so der Ansatz, den man haben will.
Das heißt, in einer idealen Welt hätten quasi alle Geräte, die so eine Wallet vorhalten,
auch so ein Secure Element und in dieser idealen Welt hätten auch diese Secure
Elements, also die Zugriffsmethoden darauf.
Würden auch moderne Kryptografie unterstützen,
die auch den Anforderungen dieser EUDI Wallet oder den wünschenswerten Features
dieser Wallet entsprechen würde, was nicht immer der Fall ist derzeit oder derzeit
eigentlich noch gar nicht der Fall ist,
gerade im Hinblick auf solche Anforderungen wie so Zero Knowledge Proofs.
Also dass man nicht irgendwie einen kompletten Personalausweis lesen muss,
um festzustellen, dass jemand 18 ist, sondern dass man einfach sagen kann,
bist du 18 und das Ding sagt.
Bin ich, man muss es auch nicht wissen, aber die Information stimmt,
das kann ich hier kryptografisch beweisen.
Und das ist halt einfach, ist halt nicht so. Also baut man das jetzt irgendwie
ein bisschen anders und das ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch nachvollziehbar,
hat aber eben den Nachteil, dass du es eben nicht offline machen kannst,
weil du irgendwie Internet brauchst.
Ja, es gibt, davon abgesehen, gibt es halt noch dieses andere Problem,
das Beweisen ist ja so das eine und irgendwas auf dem Bildschirm anzeigen ist das andere,
aber dann gibt es ja auch noch die Welt, wo du dich eben mal wirklich mit einem
Personalausweis für irgendeine Dienstleistung einloggen willst.
So der Klassiker, ich muss einen neuen Personalausweis beantragen oder ich muss
meinen Führerschein vorzeigen, um irgendwas zu bekommen.
Hier, Mietwagen oder keine Ahnung. Und dann musst du halt dann auch in irgendeiner
Form entweder andere Apps oder das Web in irgendeiner Form dieser Wolle zusammenbringen
und da fehlen halt einfach noch sichere Protokolle.
Wir hatten ja diesen Skandal hier mit der Ausweis-App vom Bund,
die in Ermangelung eines gesicherten Weges und einer Integration im Betriebssystem.
Also einem sicheren, definierten Zugang zu dem, was der Browser sieht, um eben quasi...
Durch diese App mit der Webseite zu kommunizieren, dass dann halt so Tricks
benutzt wurden wie, ja, damit das an mich weitergeleitet wird,
dann benutze so ein URL-Schema und dann steht da halt nicht HTTP,
sondern dann steht dann halt irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, Ausweis, Doppelpunkt.
Und dann registriert sich halt diese App für Ausweis und dann kommt das schon irgendwie an.
Ja, ganz nett, nur kann natürlich jede andere App sich auch irgendwie mit diesem
URL-Schema registrieren und schon hast du da so einen kleinen Man in the Middle.
Das war jetzt irgendwie kein großes Drama, nur hat halt einfach gezeigt,
dass das Ganze einfach auf sehr dünnen Beinchen steht.
Und man fragt sich natürlich, geht das nicht besser?
Natürlich geht das besser, aber dazu müssten eben die Betriebssysteme entsprechende
Methoden bereitstellen, mit denen eben so ein Trusted Channel da auch herbeigeführt werden kann.
So wie das ja Apple zum Beispiel für sein Apple Pay auch macht.
Also wenn ich da mit dem Safari im Web unterwegs bin und die Webseite sagt so,
ja also ich könnte ja auch mit Apple Pay bezahlen,
dann sagt der Safari ja ist alles supi und stellt natürlich hintenrum direkt
eine Verbindung zu den im Betriebssystem vorgesehenen Zahlungsmethoden her und
dann läuft das eben auch so.
Nur das ist natürlich nichts, was bei Party-Apps so ohne weiteres eben zur Verfügung steht.
Ist ja auch klar, weil man will ja jetzt auch nicht, dass eine App einfach daherkommt
und irgendwie auf jeder beliebigen Webseite da in den Traffic reinschnorchelt,
weil das ist nun mal die Definition von Sicherheit an der Stelle,
dass eben diese Apps eben davon auch getrennt sind.
Also vollkommen nachvollziehbar, dass das so erstmal nicht da ist,
aber das ist natürlich auch nachvollziehbar, dass man eben für so eine Wallet
sowas bräuchte und da habe ich mich halt immer gefragt, warum geht man da eigentlich
nicht auf die Hersteller zu und muss auch sagen,
bin ein bisschen davon ausgegangen, dass die das eigentlich ganz toll finden,
aber da muss ich mich ein bisschen korrigieren.
Mein Beispiel war nämlich zum Beispiel, Apple macht ja auch Führerschein in den USA.
Stellt sich raus, Apple nimmt dafür Kohle, diesen Führerschein zu autorisieren.
Wie viel habe ich nicht herausfinden können, aber es scheint tatsächlich eher
so ein Businessmodell zu sein.
Naja gut, das ist natürlich dann irgendwie problematisch, wenn man jetzt eigentlich
die Forderung aufstellt, so liebe Betriebssystemhersteller, bitteschön,
wir haben jetzt hier in der EU eine Wallet, so wir wollen das irgendwie haben,
das sind unsere Anforderungen.
Ihr müsst, wenn ihr jetzt Telefone verkaufen wollt, müsst ihr entsprechende APIs bereitstellen.
Habt ihr ja schon mal gemacht auf so Staatslevel mit der Corona-Warn-App,
gab es auch ein spezielles Framework, war auch irgendwie geregelt,
wie das läuft, da haben wir uns ja irgendwie geeinigt.
Und außerdem hätten wir gerne hier so einen definierten Zugriff auf dieses Secure
Element, das muss Mindestanforderungen entsprechen, das muss irgendwie die und die,
Kryptomethoden unterstützen können, damit wir auch unseren Zero-Knowledge-Proof
machen können und das bitteschön mal ab Datum sowieso.
Das ist so meine ideale Vorstellung und das ist ja auch ganz toll,
dass ich solche idealen Vorstellungen habe, aber da ist ja dann immer die Realität noch dazwischen.
Weil, stellt sich raus, man kann da gar nicht so ohne weiteres Einigkeit erzielen in der EU.
Tatsächlich ist es wohl so, dass in Deutschland...
Dass BSI sehr wohl das auch erkannt hat, hurra, und wohl auf EU-Ebene ganz stark
für diesen Weg auch lobbyiert.
Nur, dass andere Länder da jetzt nicht so mitziehen, wo man sich fragt so,
aha, warum denn nicht, ist doch the right thing.
Und wir müssen auch immer das machen, was das Richtige ist.
Naja, dann haben wir erstmal das Problem.
Erstens, wir haben eine ganze Menge Länder, die haben sehr wohl schon ihre eigenen
Lösungen, wie die baltischen Staaten, die dann teilweise über ESIM und was weiß ich funktionieren.
Und das läuft für die. Und für die ist halt so eine neue Anforderung, alles ist anders.
Die haben jetzt quasi mit der EU die Eiwolle, im Prinzip müssen sie ja schon irgendwas tun.
Aber haben natürlich jetzt auch nicht Bock irgendwie ihre komplette existierende
Infrastruktur ohne Not komplett umzustellen, wieder auf irgendeinen neuen Scheiß,
weil es macht ja alles nur Arbeit und deswegen singen jetzt nicht alle in diesem
Chor mit und dann mag es sicherlich auch noch ein paar Länder geben,
die wieder mal ganz generell immer dagegen sind und Ungarn-Problematik und hast
du nicht gesehen und die überhaupt auch irgendwie die Notwendigkeit nicht sehen
oder es nicht verstehen, keine Ahnung, was auch immer.
Also das ist sozusagen die Grundproblematik.
Ich fände es natürlich gut, wenn man diesen Weg weiter gehen würde,
weil dann wäre eben eine Authentifizierung offline möglich,
es wäre ordentlich ins Betriebssystem integriert, aber mein Eindruck ist,
ich glaube, dass wir da schon noch ein paar Jahre von entfernt sind,
weil es auf der einen Seite bedeuten würde,
da muss erstmal der politische Druck kommen, da müssen wir irgendwie eine Entscheidung bekommen.
Das ist ja noch nicht mal in dieser EU-Legislatur absehbar,
weil es einfach da noch überhaupt keine Einigung gibt, noch gar keinen Auftrag
für die Kommission in irgendeiner Form darauf jetzt konkret hinzuweisen,
natürlich an sich das alles voranzubringen, ja sehr wohl.
Und selbst wenn man sich dann eben einigt und sagt, okay, keine Ahnung,
in vier oder fünf Jahren haben wir dann eben auch diese Regelung so durchgesetzt
und man kann jetzt keine Telefone mehr verkaufen, wenn man das nicht hat.
Ab Datum sowieso dauert es ja dann auch nochmal, bis das auch alles implementiert und umgesetzt ist.
Also von daher muss ich sagen, okay, gut, die Welt könnte schöner sein,
aber dieser Prozess, den wir jetzt so haben, der muss jetzt auch erstmal so laufen.
Ja, ich kann dir ganz vielen zustimmen.
Also zuerst mal, was diese Architekturfrage betrifft, ja,
Serverkomponenten im konkreten Hardware-Security-Models sind so als Brückentechnologie
im Moment im Einsatz in vielen Mitgliedstaaten,
weil du einfach noch nicht diese Sicherheitschips in allen Telefonen hast,
die du unterstützen willst und musst.
Du kannst ja nicht auch Leute, die ein älteres Telefon haben,
weil sie vielleicht auch kein anderes wollen oder sich leisten können,
da ausschließen von einem staatlichen System.
Und da, wo du diese Sicherheitschips auf den Telefonen hast,
sind einfach die Operationen, die darauf ausführbar sind, sehr eingeschränkt.
Und dadurch fallen gewisse Features weg, die du eigentlich haben willst,
vor allem auch die du aus Privacy-Sicht haben willst. Zero-Noll-Spruchs gehören da auf jeden Fall dazu.
Gerade in dem Bereich gibt es angekündigte Innovationen, aber die ist noch nicht
da und das ist eher noch so auf dem akademischen Niveau.
Und da ist viel Innovation gerade im Laufen, aber das, was jetzt auch kryptografisch
vielleicht geht, dann auch auf die Hardware umzusetzen,
da hast du auch recht, dass es diesen politischen Hebel bräuchte,
um auf die Gerätehersteller einzuwirken.
Teile der Gerätehersteller sind ja auch in diesem Sprint-Funke-Prozess beteiligt
und auch sehr aktiv, andere nicht, insbesondere Apple.
Und die IDAS-Verordnung gibt dir rechtlich auch nicht den Hebel,
jetzt im Rahmen dieses Rechtsakts oder seiner Durchführungsrechtsakte,
also einer Implementing Act, so einen Druck aufzubauen.
Lustigerweise, das Gesetz zum digitalen Euro gibt dir diesen Hebel.
Im digitalen Euro wären, wir erinnern uns, Offline Digital Euro,
sehr starke Anforderungen, wie diese Sicherheitschips auf den Smartphones zusammenarbeiten müssen.
Da gibt es dann kein Herauslavieren. Nur beim digitalen Euro noch ein anderes
Fass, was man jetzt nicht aufmachen muss, aber dieses Gesetz ist noch in Verhandlung,
weder im Rat noch im Parlament gibt es eine Einigung, wie ich finde aus gutem Grund.
Aber das könnte ein Instrument sein, um dorthin zu kommen, dass die Hersteller
Zugriff geben müssen. Stimmt.
Das ist so die technologische Basis, vor der das alles sich gerade abspielt.
Und wie du auch eingangs gesagt hast, dieser Sprint Funke hat ja auch Prototyp im Namen.
Hier geht es darum, Open Source Technologie zu entwickeln.
Und natürlich ist es dann auch irgendwie absehbar,
dass es Wallets geben wird, weil Staaten müssen welche bis zum November 26 anbieten
und mindestens eine müssen sie ihrer Bevölkerung anbieten.
Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich sehr viele solcher Apps, die bald aufpoppen werden.
Und was diese Pfadabhängigkeit betrifft, ja,
du hast in nordischen Ländern Systeme, die schon im Einsatz sind,
die sehr hohe Verbreitung haben, die wollen gar nichts ändern am liebsten,
weil die mögen ihre bestehenden Systeme.
Und du hast auch was Sicherheit angeht sehr unterschiedliches Verständnis und
gerade in manchen osteuropäischen Ländern,
aber auch in Österreich ist es so, dass man da ein bisschen andere Perspektiven drauf hat.
Ja und das BSI, das ich hier sehr schätze,
wird von manchen anderen EU-Mitgliedstaaten in den Verhandlungen nicht unbedingt
geschätzt, weil das sind dann die strengen Deutschen, die immer auf Sicherheit
pochen und den anderen erzählen wollen,
wie es richtig geht und das hat auch schon zu Gegenreaktionen.
Und das aus dem Land, die aber dann am Ende immer ihre Projekte nicht hinkriegen,
die anderen alle schon ein laufendes System haben, genau, das kommt noch dazu.
Ganz oft gesagt, ja die Deutschen wollen alles super sicher haben und schaut
euch den Personalausweis an und wie viel der verwendet wird und deswegen,
wird dann ganz oft davon geredet, ja Sicherheit, Datenschutz und Verbreitung
sind alles drei Anforderungen und wir müssen in diesem Dreieck einen Mittelweg finden.
Ist so das Sprachbild, was am häufigsten verwendet wird von den Leuten,
die sich technisch auskennen. Ähm,
Da stehen wir also. Also du warst zufrieden, dass du dort warst.
Ich war es ja nie. Insofern hat mich das gerade super interessiert,
wie du das empfunden hast.
Und ja, Juryentscheidung gab es auch.
Und dazu kann ich aber nichts sagen, weil ich habe ein NDE.
Das verlinken wir auch. Ich darf nicht zu den Beratungen in der Jury was sagen.
Ja, also es war auf jeden Fall, muss ich auch sagen, gerade in dem Funded-Track,
die Sachen, die da rüberkamen, das waren auch so die, die eigentlich am charmantesten
präsentiert haben, was natürlich nicht der Grund war, weil die Entscheidung
war ja vorher schon gefallen.
Insofern fand ich das ganz gut, so eben dieses WWWallet Team halt aus den,
Forschungsinstitutionen und so ein sehr charmantes Team aus Holland,
und ja, aber alle waren sehr ansprechbar und alles war sehr gut und,
ich fand wirklich eben dieses Feedback gerade auch von den Beteiligten sehr
gut, ich hab die immer gefragt so wie findet ihr diesen Prozess,
was hat euch das gebracht und Die meinten so, es wäre einfach mega.
Also auch gerade, normalerweise hast du bei solchen Ausschreibungen ja immer
so relativ lange Zeiträume,
weil Konsortien bewerben sich, große Unternehmen und dann dauert das irgendwie
alles zwei Jahre und dann wird irgendwann mal wieder drauf geguckt und keiner
kümmert sich so wirklich drum.
Und hier ist halt so diese permanente Begleitung, bis hin, wir gucken in den
Source-Code rein, wir geben euch da konkrete Beratungen.
Also sie meinten so, ja, den hätten da reingeschaut und dann so hier,
guckt euch nochmal da an, die Zertifikate wie ihr das da irgendwie handelt und
wenn ihr das da irgendwie auseinander hält, dann lauft ihr irgendwie in Probleme
und macht das doch nochmal anders und so weiter,
also wirklich, wirklich mega, mega konkret und nah und auch diese relativ engen Deadline,
das Projekt ist ja quasi dieses Jahr gestartet,
spät Mai oder was ging es erst richtig los?
Ja, im Mai hatten wir die erste Sitzung, wo wir über die Initialen,
sechs Kandidatinnen entschieden haben.
Aus allen Bewerbungen haben wir sechs ausgewählt im Funded Track und sechs im Non-Funded Track.
Dann gab es eine Sitzung, wo wir auf vier reduziert haben und diese Woche wurde
auf zwei im Funded und zwei im Non-Funded Track reduziert.
Und in der letzten Phase, es gab auch immer Geld für den Funded Track und jetzt
in der letzten Phase waren das zweimal 450.000 Euro.
Also du hast doch recht, das ist ausreichend Geld
und jetzt soll auch noch weitergearbeitet werden für glaube ich sechs Monate
sind es und dann im Mai 25 ist mal dieser Teil abgeschlossen und das was jetzt
in dem dritten Stage noch entwickelt wird, liegt dann am Tisch.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass Technologiekomponenten davon dann auch für die
deutsche Wallet verwendet werden und vielleicht aber auch für die Wallets von
anderen Mitgliedstaaten.
Also Deutschland hat hier sicherlich mehr Aufwand betrieben und auch mehr Geld
in die Hand genommen und sich auch früher mit diesem Thema beschäftigt als in anderen Staaten.
Da ist sicherlich auch Lilith Wittmann zu danken und das Kaputtmachen der vorherigen
sehr schlechten Lösung.
Und das ist auch in Wirklichkeit eine gesunde Angst, würde ich fast sagen.
Ja, also weil in dem Projekt ist man sich auch bewusst, was hier gebaut wird,
muss auch den härtesten Anforderungen genügen und wird genau unter die Lupe genommen.
Und das ist auch richtig, weil der Staat erwartet ja, dass die Bevölkerung dann
sensible Daten dort ablegt.
Und sehr viele Systeme werden hängen an dieser Wallet. Also wenn das Sicherheitslücken
hat, kann das wirklich unschön werden und deswegen bin ich gerade froh,
dass die Angst haben und sich deswegen auch hoffentlich bemühen,
das sicher hinzubekommen.
Ja, also ich fand es erstaunlich, wie sehr der ganze Prozess gelobt wurde und wie schnell es geht.
Und dass vor allem die engen Deadlines, alle meinten, die engen Deadlines wären
extrem hilfreich gewesen.
Also weil dieser Druck wäre so gut, um sich wirklich drauf zu fokussieren,
man würde nicht Larifarien machen wir nächste Woche oder so,
da geht es wirklich zack, zack, zack, zack, zack,
hardcore wird da entwickelt aber eben schon auch mit den Mitteln,
dass man das eben alles durchziehen kann,
und ja das ist einfach ein interessantes Vorbild, würde ich auch sagen also
ich habe so den Eindruck, Sprint, gelingt das was und es ist ja auch nicht nur,
das, das sind ja auch die Anwender, die dort mit reinbringen.
Also man kann ja an diesem Prozess, wenn man jetzt Interesse hat an diesem Development,
kann man sich auch als Privatperson dort registrieren und kriegt dann irgendwie
Zugriff auf diesen ganzen Vorgang und Sourcecode und so weiter und kann da quasi mitentwickeln.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute das jetzt machen, aber es ist halt einfach möglich.
Das ist natürlich für so ein, das springt mir in meinen Kopf,
wenn ich drüber nachdenke, dass das letzten Endes ja sozusagen die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ist, die das irgendwie durchführt.
So, aber so ist das. Und gut, wie viele Privatleute jetzt dabei sind,
weiß ich nicht, aber gibt's auch.
Ich hab mit einem gesprochen, der ist halt irgendwie IT vom BAMF,
also Bundesministerium da für Migration, Flüchtlinge.
So, er meinte, er hätte sich da irgendwie sowohl als Mitarbeiter des Ministeriums
als auch als Privatperson quasi registriert und nimmt sozusagen auf zwei Arten daran teil.
Und zeigt aber auch, okay, das heißt auch jetzt die anderen Behörden haben quasi
jetzt schon die Möglichkeit, hier Feedback zu geben.
Tun das wohl auch. Also in dem Fall war das, so war es ja, okay,
was ist jetzt euer Ding? Kann man sich natürlich vorstellen.
Die haben natürlich das Problem mit Asylanträgen.
Da kommen dann halt Leute, die stehen auf einmal vor der Tür und sagen,
guten Tag, einmal Asyl bitte.
Und das ist ja auch hier gutes Recht, nur oft haben die dann einfach keinerlei Dokumente dabei.
Das heißt, du musst halt in irgendeiner Form das machen.
Erste Anforderung im Feedback war dann so, ja Leute, schön, dass ihr eure Wallets
macht, aber guckt mal, alle eure Wallets fangen erstmal an mit guten Tag,
geben sie ihren Personalausweis ein.
Ja, haben die Leute aber gar nicht. Den kriegen sie vielleicht irgendwann,
aber erst wenn sie eben drei andere Stufen vorher der Registrierung,
und am Ende auch der Anerkennung ihres Status durchgehabt haben,
dann erst kriegen sie quasi einen Personalausweis.
Und um eben auch solche Identifizierungssysteme dort digital abbilden zu können,
ist dann halt einfach dieses Feedback zum frühen Zeitpunkt auch möglich.
Also es ist alles sehr agil und ich war einfach erstaunt, wie positiv das bewertet
wurde und ich habe da auch ehrlich gesagt wenig dran auszusetzen.
Ja, es ist aber auch total wichtig jetzt hier hinzuschauen, weil natürlich werden
die Systeme, die wir hier bauen, gerade bei den Menschen,
die am wenigsten Lobby haben, die am wenigsten Macht in demokratischen Gefüge genießen,
diejenigen, wo die Schutzschranken nach unten ausprobiert werden und wie wenig man tun kann.
Also ich bin ja auch auf UN-Ebene zu diesem Digital Identity Thema unterwegs,
wo man es Digital Public Infrastructure nennt aus komischen Gründen und da ist es halt auch so,
wir haben in Schweden ein Digital Identity System, das ist relativ gut in manchen
Hinsichten, aber die Sachen, die die schwedische Entwicklungshilfe in Afrika
finanziert, haben alle diese Schutzschranken nicht.
Und ich glaube, so wird es auch in vielen EU-Ländern im Migrationsbereich sein,
dass man dann halt Identitätsdokumente auch digital ausstellt, um gewisse,
Dinge vielleicht auszuprobieren oder zu schauen, ob man hier Kontrolle ausüben
kann oder auch einfach nur Informationen über das Leben der Menschen zu sammeln
und da muss man sehr genau hinschauen.
Ja, im,
Im Non-Funded-Track sollte man vielleicht noch erwähnen,
also im Non-Funded-Track die Projekte, die da raus,
das habe ich vorhin falsch gesagt, dieses WW-Wallet ist ja im Non-Funded-Track,
weil die werden ja schon von der EU-Kommission unterstützt.
Also die sind weitergekommen und das andere, was weitergekommen ist,
ist diese Lissi-ID-Wallet, die wiederum einfach eine Company ist, ein deutsches Startup,
wurde mal von der Commerzbank gegründet.
Ich habe auch mal gefragt, wie die eigentlich so denken, Geld zu verdienen,
weil man kann ja mit dieser Wallet kein Geld verdienen.
Das ist eigentlich nur, um irgendwie da sozusagen technologisch am Start zu sein, sichtbar zu sein.
Die machen dann eben dann quasi ihr Geld mit Lösungen für Unternehmen,
die dann eben wirklich ihre Ausweise dort autorisieren wollen.
Also was weiß ich, wenn jetzt eine Krankenversicherung da ihre Krankenversicherungskarte
reinhaben will, dann brauchen die natürlich dann in irgendeiner Form eine Anbindung,
um da online diesen ganzen Autorisierungsprozess zu machen und da sehen die
sich dann eben so als Dienstleister entweder,
was weiß ich, mit Libraries oder System as a Service oder sowas.
Genau, das heißt Samsung und Google hatten ja noch ein Team,
die sind dann sozusagen in diesem Stage aussortiert worden und bei dem Funded
Track gibt es das Heidi Projekt,
toller Name, humanzentrierte EID-Infrastruktur und eben das schon von mir erwähnte
holländische Team Animo.
Ja, mit denen hatte ich leider Kontakt, da kann ich nicht viel zu sagen, genau,
das ist alles von dieser Jury entschieden worden, das waren 8,
9, 10 Leute genau, wo du auch dabei warst und ja das ist jetzt so das Ding und so geht's weiter.
Wunderbar. Dann kommen wir zum nächsten Thema. Ich wollte nochmal kurz auf die
UN-Cybercrime-Convention zu sprechen kommen.
Wir erinnern uns, dieser internationale Vertrag aller UN-Staaten,
aller 194 Staaten dieser Welt, da sind wir als Episenter Works schon seit zwei Jahren dran,
Verhandlungen in Wien und in New York.
Wir waren dabei, wir haben berichtet, wir haben ganz laut kritisiert,
dass hier ein Vertrag geschrieben wird,
der ganz viel Überwachung festschreibt und der auch Verpflichtungen für die
Kooperation und Datenweitergabe zwischenstaatlich regelt.
Auch die Kanäle, über die justiziell zusammengearbeitet wird,
auf komplett neue Beine stellt, sodass
das viel leichter und schneller und grenzüberschreitender passieren kann.
Man könnte auch sagen, ohne Grundrechtsschutz, ohne Rechtsstaatlichkeit.
Und dieser Vertrag, der wurde ja schon im Drafting Committee einstimmig angenommen
und jetzt sind wir an einer kritischen Stelle. Am 11.
November ist das Ganze schon durch das Third Committee gegangen.
Das ist ein Gremium, was sich eigentlich um Menschenrechte kümmert.
Auch da gab es eigentlich eine klare Mehrheit dafür.
Aber die ersten kritischen Stimmen, die USA lustigerweise, haben sich in vielen
Punkten der Kritik der Zivilgesellschaft und anderer Stakeholder angeschlossen.
Und die USA haben auch angekündigt, dass sie den Vertrag in der derzeitigen
Form weder unterzeichnen noch ratifizieren werden.
Ich komme gleich drauf, was diese zwei Wörter in dem Kontext bedeuten.
Aber die USA drücken jetzt hier die Pause-Taste und sagen, wir müssen da nochmal drüber reden.
Und wir brauchen Protokolle, die dem Ganzen beigefügt werden,
die sich um menschenrechtliche Garantien kümmern.
Weil wenn wir jetzt hier wirklich Zugriff auf die Server in unserem Land und
die vielen Daten, die die beinhalten, geben sollen, dann muss das unter stärkeren
Garantien ablaufen, da muss Rechtsstaatlichkeit eingehalten sein.
Und wohlgemerkt sagt das die Biden-Administration, natürlich ist die nicht mehr
lange im Amt, in wenigen Wochen ist Trump dann dort am Ruder.
Es gibt doch hier Hoffnung, weil Donald Trump ist jetzt nicht der Fan des Multilateralismus
und des Völkerrechts und der internationalen Verträge.
Oder der UN, ja.
Aber würden die USA jetzt hier auf die Pausetaste drücken, eröffnet das natürlich
dann auch für Europa einen gewissen Handlungsdruck.
Dieser Handlungsdruck ist deswegen so stark, weil bereits nächste Woche tagt
die UN-Generalversammlung.
Und dort steht dieses Thema auf der Agenda.
Irgendwann zwischen 15. und 20. Dezember sollte dort abgestimmt werden.
Es braucht eine Zweidrittelmehrheit, die...
Und damit das Ganze ein internationaler Vertrag sein kann, wir haben uns auch
gerade erst wieder mit 29 NGOs in einem offenen Brief an die UNO gewendet, das bitte nicht zu tun.
Da ist es aber so, dass einfach eine klare Mehrheit für den Vertrag als solchen
mal da ist, dass er als Vertrag verabschiedet wird, aber da ist dann der nächste Punkt sozusagen,
was passiert denn, sobald das ein Vertragswerk wird.
Einerseits gibt es ab dem Zeitpunkt eine Zuständigkeit des Europaparlaments.
Im Europaparlament kann man sich dann auch zu diesem Vertrag äußern.
Man hat auch gewisse Möglichkeiten, das vor den EuGH zu bringen.
Was heißt, ab welchem Zeitpunkt, warum hat die Europa da einen? Ich verstehe nicht.
Das Europaparlament kann sich noch nicht zu irgendeinem Vorschlag äußern,
der auf UNO-Ebene durch Committees geht und diskutiert wird,
aber sobald die Generalversammlung das als Vertrag annimmt,
wo ja auch die Erwartungshaltung ist, dass der von allen Staaten der Welt und
somit auch der EU unterschrieben wird und dann auch ratifiziert,
da hat dann das Europaparlament eine Möglichkeit sich dazu zu äußern.
Meine Kollegin Tanja Facherteiler, die ja da bei dem Thema eigentlich die Expertin
ist, war dazu schon als Expertin geladen im Parlament,
gemeinsam mit dem UN-Menschenrechtskommissariat, haben wir da unsere Kritik
wiederholt und es gibt da schon Bewegung,
was genau wird man dann im nächsten Jahr sehen.
Wir können nicht alles dazu sagen, was wir planen, aber es gibt Hoffnung.
Zuerst wird es aber auch eine Signing Ceremony geben in Hanoi, in Vietnam.
Das ist deswegen ein bisschen brisant, weil ich habe ja schon erwähnt,
wir haben nicht nur die Sorge über diese massiven Sorge.
Also Straftatbestände, die hier kommen, dass man teilweise ja wirklich auch
religiöse Diffamierung hier kriminalisieren
will, dass es ganz stark die Meinungsfreiheit einschränken könnte.
Computerkriminalität wird so definiert, dass ganz viel Whitehead-Hacker und
Responsible Disclosure kriminalisiert werden könnte.
Und die Werkzeuge, Stichwort Hacker-Paragraph.
Wir haben auch diese ganze Frage der zwischenstaatlichen Zusammenarbeit,
die hier neu geregelt wird.
Und dazu gab es einen Antrag in den Verhandlungen vom Iran, unterstützt von
Russland und vielen anderen Staaten, die jetzt nicht Freunde der Freiheit sind.
Und dieser Antrag wollte diese wenigen Menschenrechtsstandards und diese Schutzschranken
für die Kooperation zwischen staatlicher Natur auch nochmal wegräumen.
Zum Beispiel die Dual Criminality.
Ich gebe dir nur Daten zu einer Straftat, wenn das bei mir auch illegal ist.
Das sogenannte Dual Criminality.
Ich kann jetzt nicht wegen irgendeiner Verunglimpfung des Propheten aus Deutschland
Daten mir besorgen als Staat.
Das wollte man mit diesem Antrag auch ausräumen.
Dieser Antrag fand keine Mehrheit, aber es gab eine Gruppe von Ländern,
die haben den zugestimmt, ca.
30 Staaten und dann noch eine Gruppe von Leuten, die haben sich enthalten bei
diesem hochkritischen Vertrag, darunter auch Vietnam.
Also das Fest zu diesem Vertrag wird dort abgehalten, wo man sehr genau ablesen
kann, wie dieser Vertrag gelesen wird, wie er gelebt wird und was damit eigentlich
bei manchen Staaten das Ziel ist.
Und natürlich haben Russland, China und andere Staaten hier ein Ziel.
Es gibt jetzt schon die nächsten Vorschläge zur Cybersicherheit von Russland,
eine neue UNO-Konvention zu machen.
Also Russland ist sehr aktiv auf UN-Ebene, wenn es um die Regulierung des Internets
und von digitaler Technik geht.
Die haben da einen großen Plan, die haben viel vor und das ist nur der erste Stein des Anstoßes.
Und wir haben dann auch noch Verhandlungen zu einem sogenannten Second Protocol,
die beginnen in zwei Jahren, also ein ergänzendes Protokoll zu dem Vertrag,
wo auch nochmal ganz viel festgelegt wird.
Und Europa muss sich jetzt einfach mal entscheiden, wie stehen sie zu all dem.
Im Moment ist es so, dass die EU-Kommission, insbesondere die G-Home,
Also das Innenkommissariat unter Magnus Brunner, dem österreichischen Innenkommissar,
da er sagt, ja, we want to have a seat on the table instead of being on the
menu und wir müssen da jetzt dabei sein und der Vertrag ist doch super,
das ist ein Erfolg, schnell, schnell, schnell unterzeichnen und wir rufen genau zum anderen auf.
Wir sagen, nein, jetzt dabei zu sein, noch bevor die Amerikaner das unterzeichnet
haben, wäre ein desaströses Signal für die Menschenrechte.
Hier hat Europa auch eine Verantwortung.
Die EU muss jetzt weg vom Tempo gehen und sich diesen Menschenrechtsfragen kümmern,
bevor man dieses Instrument offiziell annimmt.
Da haben wir national in jedem der 27 Mitgliedstaaten eine Chance und auf EU-Ebene
auch nochmal im Parlament und in der Kommission und im Rat.
Wenn der Vertrag jetzt nächste Woche von der Generalversammlung angenommen wird,
dann ist bei jedem anderen Staat sozusagen die Frage, unterschreiben wir das
und oder ratifizieren wir das.
Die Unterschrift passiert mal bei der Signing Ceremony, kann aber auch im Nachgang geleistet werden.
Das ist sowas wie ein Versprechen oder eine Absichtserklärung,
dass man diesen Vertrag annimmt, für sich selber auch recognized.
Und wenn man ihn dann noch ratifiziert, das bedeutet, dass man ihn in nationales
Recht überführt, dass er auch rechtliche Bindung hat.
Und sobald das passiert ist, kannst du als Iran, wenn die auch ratifiziert haben,
hergehen und sagen, hey, hier, Cybercrime Convention, ich hätte gerne diese Daten, bitte.
Und damit wird halt einfach ein neuer harmonisierter Weg geschaffen,
wie Daten fließen können, wie Polizei und Justiz zusammenarbeitet und halt eben auch,
wie Überwachungsmethoden sich weltweit verbreiten können.
Ja, und wir verlinken dazu auch nochmal das Forderungspapier,
was wir jetzt für Österreich geschrieben haben.
Das ist, glaube ich, für Deutschland eins zu eins so umsetzbar.
Für die, ja, jetzt bald laufende Wahl und den Wahlkampf und dann auch die Koalitionsverhandlungen.
Es wäre, glaube ich, sehr wichtig, dass man hier auf die Pause-Taste drückt
und nicht blind einfach diesem Vertrag hinterherläuft.
Ist eh ein bisschen fragwürdig, warum auf einmal hier Russland und Iran irgendwie
in diesem Segment da so einen Vorstoß machen können und da irgendwie alle mitziehen.
Ich habe so den Eindruck, die haben sich das alles noch gar nicht so richtig
durchgelesen. Ich meine, diese Geschichte mit dieser Auslieferung,
das Prinzip, also gerade was du gesagt hast hier mit Double Criminality,
das gibt es ja im Prinzip auch innerhalb der EU schon.
Also wenn auch innerhalb der EU irgendwas, irgendeine Auslieferung beantragst.
Ich glaube, wir hatten diesen Fall bei diesem Putschdemont, bei dem katalanischen
Separatistenführer. in Belgien.
Der nach Belgien abgedüstet. Ich glaube, da war dann auch sowas in dem Bereich,
bin mir nicht ganz sicher, vielleicht wechsle ich das gerade, auf jeden Fall ist es so,
klar, wenn also jetzt Land X, was weiß ich, von Deutschland jetzt irgendjemanden
haben will, und die vorgeworfene Straftat existiert in Deutschland nicht,
dann gilt das halt erstmal nicht. Aber mit der Ausnahme von,
bestimmten Straftaten, die halt so Terrorismus, Da ist es dann sozusagen egal.
Und wie breitbandig solche Vorwürfe natürlich genutzt werden,
speziell im Cyber-Bereich, wissen wir natürlich alle.
Naja, okay, gut, also es ist auf jeden Fall ein Prozess, der sich noch verhindern lässt.
Ja, also es ist zum Beispiel auch das von dir angesprochene Beispiel,
Terrorismus ist natürlich auch in Belgien eine Straftat, aber da greift neben
der Dual Criminality noch dieser weitere Passus,
den du in ganz vielen Jurisdiktionen kennst, dass wenn jetzt eine Person in
einem Land politisch verfolgt wird oder aufgrund von ihrer Geschlechtsidentität,
ethnischer Zugehörigkeit, Religion,
dann sind das valide Gründe, dass du die Auslieferung der Person oder ihrer Daten, verweigerst.
Und auch das war Teil von diesem Änderungsantrag.
Also das wollte Russland weghaben. Weil natürlich, wenn sich jetzt ein Nawalny
in Deutschland aufhält, um sich von seiner Novichok-Vergiftung zu erholen,
kann Russland sich auf den Kopf stellen, Deutschland wird ihn nicht ausliefern.
Genau wegen solcher Bestimmungen.
Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass es noch Auslieferungsabkommen zwischen Russland
und Deutschland gibt, aber Aber so wäre die Rechtslage.
Deswegen hat Belgien und Spanien, die ja beide in der EU sind,
ist Carlos Putschdemont in Belgien sicher vor der spanischen Justizkanzlerin.
Ich hoffe, ich verwechsel da jetzt nicht, ob das jetzt wirklich der Grund war,
warum er nicht ausgeliefert wurde.
Aber egal, wer auch immer. Auf jeden Fall allgemein gilt das natürlich genauso.
Genug von der UN, wir haben lustige Sachen aus Rumänien zu berichten.
Ja, super. Sehr lustig, auf jeden Fall.
Rumänien, ja, ja. What happened? Also es gab ja Wahlen und für eine neue Regierung
in Rumänien und da war der Aufschrei nach der Wahl auch extrem groß, weil,
also die Wahl wurde nicht final entschieden, weil auch hier eine notwendige
absolute Mehrheit nicht erreicht wurde für die Präsidentschaftswahl und
Und das Ganze eben jetzt in den nächsten Tagen eigentlich in eine Stichwahl
münden sollte. Warum gab es so einen großen Aufschrei?
Weil ein rechtsgerichteter Kandidat, den vorher so keiner so richtig auf dem
Zettel hatte, einen extrem hohen Stimmenanteil erreicht hat und es durchaus
denkbar gewesen wäre, dass er auch diese Präsidentschaft unter Umständen gewinnt.
Ich war auf jeden Fall nicht sicher, dass er das nicht tut.
Und alle wunderten sich, warum denn der auf einmal so viele Stimmen bekam und
stellt sich raus, es gab einfach eine massive Kampagne klassischer Natur,
Anti-Flüchtlinge pro russischer Natur auf TikTok und auch auf vielen anderen Social Media Kanälen.
Und naja, da kann man dann schon mal sehr ins Grübeln und zu unserer Überraschung,
ich weiß nicht wie sehr überraschend das jetzt innerhalb von Rumänien war,
letzten Endes gab es jetzt eine Entscheidung des obersten Gerichts,
des Verfassungsgerichtes in Rumänien dass diese Wahl ungültig ist und komplett
zu wiederholen ist. Warum?
Weil es Cyberangriffe gegeben hat auf die Wahlinfrastruktur,
der rumänischen Wahlbehörde.
Hier wird von 85.000 Fällen berichtet, die aus 33 Ländern versucht haben,
diverse Schwachstellen in den Software-Systemen auszunutzen.
Klassische SQL Injection, Cross-Site-Kram etc.
Wahlbezogene Webseiten, Deren Zugangsdaten wurden dabei eröffnet,
wurden dabei erbeutet und unter anderem in russischen Hackerforen veröffentlicht.
Also mit anderen Worten, die ganze Wahlinfrastruktur wurde beobachtet.
Es gab die Manipulation von öffentlichen Wahlinformationen,
es wurde teilweise der Zugang zu bestimmten Wahlsystemen wurde dann dadurch
verweigert eben und dazu.
Diverse TikTok-Influencer mit irgendwie über 8 Millionen Followern wurden wohl
bezahlt, um Inhalte für diesen,
Präsidentschaftskandidaten Karlin, John, Jescu zu verbreiten.
Nachdem diese Ankündigung kam, sind auch viele von diesen Influencern auf einmal
fluchtartig das Land verlassen.
Man fragt sich warum.
Offensichtlich haben die wohl Angst, dass da was dran sein könnte. Warum nur?
Und halt diese typischen Sachen. Also 25 TikTok-Konten, die vor der Wahl auf
einmal aktiv wurden, die vorher nur so schläfermäßig rumlagen.
Man kennt dieses ganze Schema schon.
So läuft das generell mit russischen Social-Media-Aktivitäten.
Das kann man im Ukraine-Krieg beobachten. Man hatte ja Ähnliches auch schon
in Moldau beobachtet, wo ja auch fast die Wahl gekippt wäre.
Das war da alles sehr knapp.
Da kam es jetzt nicht zu einer Annullierung, aber man kann sich echt fragen,
was passiert wäre, wenn man das nicht so gut beobachtet hätte.
Ja, und sehr offensichtlich, dass also hier massive russische Einflussnahme stattgefunden hat.
Ich meine, Rumänien gehört halt auch zu den starken Unterstützern der Ukraine
und Und ja, das ist jetzt eben die Entscheidung gewesen.
Mit anderen Worten, die Wahl wurde komplett annulliert, weil man einfach gesagt
hat, hier wurde zu viel Einfluss genommen und es müssen neue Wahlen kommen.
Ja, was lernen wir daraus?
Computer und Wahlen, ganz schlechte Idee.
Ich meine, lässt sich natürlich jetzt hier nicht komplett vermeiden.
Selbstverständlich will man Webseiten haben, wo Informationen drauf sind.
Selbstverständlich sollten die so gesichert sein, dass diese Informationen sich
dann nicht ändern können.
Auf jeden Fall muss man sicherstellen, dass die Security-Anforderungen für alles,
was wahlbezogen ist, extrem hoch ist und natürlich sollte man vor allem keine
Wahlcomputer verwenden.
Das war jetzt hier glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt der Fall,
aber hätte natürlich hier auch ein Thema sein können.
Ja und in dem Zusammenhang ist auch ganz interessant, dass ja auch die EU eine
Aufbewahrungsanordnung jetzt verfügt hat an TikTok,
was sozusagen nächste Wahlen in Europa betrifft.
Das ist also auch unsere nächste Bundestagswahl hier in Deutschland,
sprich TikTok wird verpflichtet, alle Informationen abzuspeichern über Empfehlungsalgorithmen,
sie müssen irgendwie ganzen eigenen Maßnahmen gegen Manipulationen,
die also verhindern sollen, dass irgendwas nicht autorisiert verwendet wird,
müssen sie dokumentieren.
Sie müssen Hinweise sichern etc. Also ein ganzer Katalog von Vorgaben und das ist natürlich auch.
Beeinflusst durch die Vorgänge jetzt in Rumänien. Also ich bin schon mal ganz
froh, dass jetzt hier in gewisser Hinsicht was gemacht wird.
Wobei man dazu sagen muss, TikTok ist jetzt nicht das einzige Problem.
Also TikTok ist gerade ein Riesenproblem, weil es einfach super,
super populär ist, speziell bei jungen Leuten, aber auch nicht unbedingt nur,
aber das sind halt auch schon fast so naja.
Also Echo kann man für sich, weil es halt einfach auch normal geworden ist,
aus diesen Short-Video-Kanälen auch seine Informationen zu ziehen.
Und wir wissen alle, ich meine, mach mal so TikTok mal so auf,
ohne so neu, ja, also wenn du sozusagen keinen Account hast,
keine History, nichts, du bist so ein fresh User,
installierst dir einfach mal TikTok und fängst an durchzuscrollen,
du fällst komplett hinten über.
Es ist einfach ein ausländerfeindliches, hetzerischer Content,
der dir da entgegensprudelt.
Es macht einfach keinen Spaß.
Und ich meine, es ist halt einfach so, dass diese ganzen Social Media Systeme
durchsetzt sind von Bots und Akteuren und es funktioniert.
Weil einfach TikTok erreicht, auch in den USA, mehr Leute als die klassischen
Fernsehsender das heutzutage noch tun.
Und darauf muss reagiert werden.
Schön, dass sie jetzt hier irgendwie Dokumentationszwang haben.
Wie viel es hilft, wird man dann sehen.
Sicherlich jetzt kein Fehler, was sie gemacht haben, aber man muss natürlich
sehr viel Gedanken generell über die Durchführung von Wahlen zukünftig machen.
Aber ich finde es, eigentlich ist es erschreckend, dass das passiert ist,
dass es diese Ausmaße angenommen hat. Es ist die Wahlmanipulation durch Russland.
Aber dieser Schritt des Höchstgerichtes, die Wahl zu annullieren,
halte ich eigentlich wirklich für richtig.
Also das ist ja so, wie wenn man sagt, okay, ihr habt hier geschummelt,
das war nicht fair und dieses Spiel wird jetzt wiederholt und ihr seid damit nicht durchgekommen.
Das ist sicherlich besser fürs Land, als wenn jetzt ein russlandfreundlicher
und EU-feindlicher, ukrainefeindlicher Politiker hier das Amt gewonnen hätte.
Und dass es einfach auch eine Konsequenz gibt. Ja, dieser Einflussnahme ist so mannigfaltig.
Das haben wir ja auch schon seit 2015 zuhauf diskutiert.
Und dass es da einfach auch Konsequenzen gibt. Und man sagt,
na, wenn das keine faire Wahl war, dann könnt ihr so nicht ein Ergebnis erzwingen.
Und dass man da jetzt auch Kontrollinstrumente einbaut und dass wir auch hier
versuchen, dann die Evidenz zu sammeln. Und ich glaube, dass eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
Anstrengung notwendig ist.
Das ist sicherlich was, wo die Justiz,
aber auch der Journalismus und die Zivilgesellschaft und andere Behörden,
die sich ja sonst schon für das Abhalten von sauberen Wahlen zuständig sind,
dass man da jetzt halt auch wirklich genauer diesen neuen Phänomenen sich widmen
muss, weil Russland darf einfach damit nicht davon kommen.
Also ich bin...
Ich bin erschreckt, aber irgendwie auch positiv gestimmt, dass das jetzt so ausgegangen ist.
Die Propaganda ist ja dadurch auch nicht weg. Also TikTok ist jetzt nicht auf
einmal ein Happy Place geworden.
Also das Problem existiert und vor allem ist ja nach wie vor in den Köpfen.
Die Leute haben ja irgendwie einen Grund gesehen, irgendwie diesen Typen zu wählen.
Es gibt ja jetzt keine unbedingten Erkenntnisse, dass jetzt sozusagen die Wahlergebnisse
als solche manipuliert wurden, wobei keine Ahnung was da noch rauskommt.
Die Manipulation findet ja in den Köpfen statt und die sind ja im Prinzip schon manipuliert.
Und du kannst natürlich auch schnell in deiner Propaganda so auf,
oh jetzt wollen sie ihn stumm schalten und weißt du, wir müssen uns jetzt wehren,
genau, Deep State, Verschwörungstheorien und so.
Also da ist jetzt sicherlich noch nicht alles im grünen Bereich,
nur muss man sich halt drüber Gedanken machen, muss man auch nochmal schauen,
wie sich das jetzt weiterentwickelt, wann es da überhaupt einen neuen Termin
gibt und wie die sich das denken,
aber muss sich eben auch Gedanken darüber machen, wie man dem Herr werden will.
Und am Ende muss man sagen, der Quell des Problems ist schon das Netzwerk als solches.
Also es ist halt einfach, Social Media ist so ein Krebs geworden und es ist
so, das Maß, in dem es manipulierbar ist,
übersteigt das Maß, in dem es sinnvoll ist, daran teilzunehmen.
So sehr mittlerweile, dass ich halt schon ich meine, wir hatten schon diese Diskussion jetzt über,
Australiens Reaktion, die gesagt haben, wir müssen hier unsere Kinder schützen.
TikTok nur noch ab 16. Ja, gut, aber die unter 16 werden jetzt in Rumänien nicht gewählt haben.
Also es ist vollkommen egal, in welchem Alter du bist. es schadet dir sozusagen
in jedem Alter und oder es schadet auch vor allem der Gesellschaft wo man sich
dann eben auch einfach fragt so können wir uns.
Sowas überhaupt leisten, also was ist denn bitte der gesellschaftliche Gewinn,
der offensichtlichen Vorteile, die solche Systeme ja auch haben,
weil wir nutzen ja auch alle Social Media eben auf unserer Art und wir wollen
irgendwie nicht gleich das System zum Umsturz bringen und den Putschdämon beschwören,
sondern wir wollen halt einfach ordentlich kommunizieren und Spaß haben,
nur damit sind wir dann halt sozusagen eine totale Minderheit,
weil die allermeisten Leute sich unterhalten wollen,
Also miteinander unterhalten wollen, beziehungsweise sich unterhalten sehen wollen.
Also die vor Entertainment sind, die Fun machen, die ihre Idole dort anhimmeln, okay,
aber wenn die Idole dann bezahlt werden und dann irgendwie gegen Geld Propaganda
raushauen, und das hatten wir ja auch in den USA schon, das gibt es ja auch
in Deutschland auch durchaus.
Dann ist halt die Gefahr für die Gesellschaft so groß, dass ich schon an so
einem Punkt bin, wo ich mir sage, wozu das Ganze? Also das kann man irgendwie auch anders haben.
Da braucht ihr irgendwie eine.
Sendelizenz oder so. Also ich bin da auch ratlos.
Aber so geht es nicht. Weil das lässt alles zusammenbrechen.
Das ist ein riesiges Thema.
Freiheit hin, Freiheit her, aber irgendwo es gibt dann einfach keine Freiheit mehr.
Also wir wollen, wenn man diese Art von Freiheit mit irgendwie jeder darf jederzeit
alles erzählen, was er will, im Sinne von,
selbst wenn es Propaganda ist und irgendwie alles zum Brennen bringt,
was haben wir denn dann davon?
Also das ist schon eine Abwägung, wo man mal in sich gehen muss,
weil wir sind natürlich alle beseelt von unserem Traum eines freien,
Internets und haben auch immer geglaubt, wenn irgendwie alle frei miteinander
kommunizieren können auf Twitter, dann wird die Welt ein happy place und wir
werden alle das Licht sehen. Ja, einen Scheiß tun wir.
Es ist halt einfach genau das Gegenteil und das ist bedrückend,
aber es ist halt auch einfach mal Teil der Realität und das muss,
glaube ich, in diese ganze Diskussion mit rein,
dass wir da einen Weg finden müssen.
Ich sage ja nicht gleich alles verbieten, alles abschalten, alles doof, nur,
Da sind Kompromisse einfach erforderlich und bald.
Ja, ich meine, ich finde es spannend, dass hier der Digital Services Act zur
Anwendung gebracht wird, weil der ist ja der Vorschlag der EU,
solche und andere Probleme durch Social Media und andere Mitmachplattformen zu lösen.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal, ob er das leisten kann. Ich finde,
hier muss man auch einfach mal jetzt einen Reality Check machen.
Es gibt ja viele Ansätze. Das von dir angesprochene, du brauchst eine Lizenz,
bevor du ein soziales Netzwerk machen kannst.
Ich habe so nicht den Detail angeschaut, aber mein Verständnis von dem neuen
indischen Telekomrecht ist genau das.
Du brauchst eine Lizenz für ein soziales Netzwerk.
Keine Ahnung, wie gut das funktioniert. Ist sicher das Gegenteil von Innovation
without Permission, aber es
gibt natürlich auch wiederum mehr staatliche Handhabe bei diesen Dingen.
Also ja, das ist.
Wie mit Wettbüros. Ich meine, wenn du irgendwie Wetten anbieten willst,
ich finde es sowieso scheiße, dass es die gibt, so die ganzen Wettdinger, aber zumindest.
Die sitzen alle in Malta und sind nicht reguliert.
Ja gut, aber auch da könnte man mehr machen. Ich meine, also generell es ist
jetzt sozusagen kein neuartiges Konzept, dass man sagt, ja könnt ihr schon machen, Aber Regeln.
Und wenn ihr die nicht haltet, dann Ende. Und das ist schon so ein Damoklesschwert,
was dann eben auch für eine gewisse Konformität sorgt, weil man hat ja was zu verlieren.
Und klar, jetzt kannst du natürlich sagen, ja Internet, Erreichbarkeit und die
Leute können ja immer drüber teilnehmen und so weiter.
Und jetzt macht ihr ja irgendwie bald wie Russland dann irgendwie den eisernen
Vorhang dann ins Internet.
Klar, die Problematik hast du natürlich auch. Aber es ist natürlich für diese
Unternehmen auch problematisch, wenn sie irgendwie keine Werbedienst mehr machen,
wenn sie irgendwie sozusagen businessmäßig nicht auftauchen können und irgendwann
ist dann eben auch da Ende.
Also man hat da schon einen Einfluss und da muss man sich wahrscheinlich über
eine Regulierung, über eine noch weitergehende Regulierung Gedanken machen,
weil ehrlich gesagt, ich habe einfach keinen Bock für lustige Memes aus dem Internet,
gebe ich hier nicht meine Demokratie auf.
Ja, da bin ich bei dir, nicht einmal für Katzenbilder.
Ja, nicht mal da.
Um lustig zu enden, also diese rumänischen Influencer, die da auf der Payroll
von Russland standen, wissen wir wohin die geflohen sind?
Also wenn die nach Russland geflohen sind, langsam könnte man wirklich ein sehr
lustiges satirisches Projekt machen mit all den Leuten, die Russland schon aufgesogen hat.
Also wir haben da Jan Marsalek, Bashar Al-Assad, diese ganzen rumänischen Influencer,
Karin Kneisel, die ehemalige Außenministerin aus Österreich.
Es gibt langsam so eine Mannschaft dort.
Also wenn Sacha Baron Cohen vielleicht einen neuen Film macht,
da könnte man auf jeden Fall drüber lachen.
Ja, und Edward Snowden sitzt da auch noch rum. Also das ist eine interessante Party.
Gehen wir weiter. Ich wollte hier kurz vermelden und wir werden das nicht in
aller Tiefe behandeln können.
Was?
Dazu der Cyber Resilience Act.
Achso.
Weil der ist gestern am 11. Dezember in Kraft getreten und das ist ein Gesetz, das es in sich hat.
Also das ist eine EU-Verordnung, die baut auf auf der NIST-2-Richtlinie.
Die NIST-2 kümmert sich ja um alles, was so kritische Systeme und Infrastrukturen sind.
Und beim Cyber Resilience Act geht es um Produkte.
Um die IT-Sicherheit von Connected Products, also alles, was man ans Internet
anschließt, was irgendwie sendet, empfängt,
alles, was in einem Smart Home ist, Babymonitor,
aber auch wirklich Software-Komponenten, also Open-Source-Libraries zum Beispiel auch.
Gerade vielleicht nicht Open-Source, weil da gibt es eine kleine Ausnahme,
dazu kommen wir gleich, aber auch alles, was du so als Library anbietest,
alle Wearables, Computerspiele, bis hin zu Firewalls und Routern,
all das ist hier umfasst mit diesem neuen Gesetz,
und Ziel ist, die IT-Sicherheit zu erhöhen.
Das heißt, es gibt verschiedene Pflichten, die man den Anbietern dieser Software
und Hardware auferlegt.
Da geht es einerseits um Also Mindestsicherheitsanforderungen,
also ab wann gewisse Produkte hier gemäß ihrer Risikoklasse,
da muss man sich klassifizieren, eben gewisse Anforderungen erfüllen müssen.
Also das, was so Best Practice ist, wie zum Beispiel Verschlüsselung im Transportweg oder Addressed.
Und es gibt auch Anforderungen für den Umgang mit Sicherheitslücken,
was ich sehr wichtig finde.
Also wie der Informationsaustausch darüber passieren muss.
Es ist verpflichtend, eine Coordinated Vulnerability Disclosure zu machen.
Also wie geht man um, wenn einem Sicherheitslücken gemeldet werden?
Das finde ich super wichtig, weil hier ist es ja leider oft auch so,
auch in Deutschland und in Österreich, kann ich auch ein Lied davon singen,
weil da war ich schon mal Beschuldigter, dass auch wenn man Responsible Disclosure
macht und Sicherheitslücken meldet,
wird man auf einmal als Beschuldigter geführt oder angezeigt.
Da könnte dieses Gesetz helfen.
Dieses uns allen bekannte CE-Label für Konformität mit, zum Beispiel wenn man
was sicher an Stromnetz anstecken kann,
wird hier ausgeweitet, um eben auch die Sicherheitskonformität auszudrücken.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, ganz gut, damit Leuten einfach auf den ersten Blick
bewusst ist, wenn sie Produkte kaufen,
sind die sicher genug, um am europäischen Markt betrieben zu werden,
verkauft zu werden. Und es gibt auch eine Update-Pflicht.
Also wenn man Produkte auf den Markt bringt, wird es nicht so,
dass die dann drei Monate später schon keine Sicherheits-Updates mehr bekommen.
Also insgesamt...
Verbesserungen, sicherlich kein optimales Gesetz, aber scheint mir ein Schritt
in die richtige Richtung zu sein, der jetzt eben seit gestern 11. Dezember in Kraft ist.
Es wird aber natürlich dann gestaffelt erst gewisse Dinge in Kraft treten.
Also das vollständige Gesetz ist dann in allen Bereichen anwendbar ab dem 11.
Dezember 2027.
Also da ist noch ein bisschen was hin, aber man darf sich jetzt schon freuen.
Die Strafen sind relativ signifikant mit bis zu 15 Millionen Euro oder 2,5 Prozent
des gesamten weltweiten Jahresumsatzes.
Ja, Cyber Resilience Act gibt es jetzt auch.
Ja, weißt du, ob es auch eine Regelung gibt zu was mit Produkten passiert,
wo die Firma pleite, insolvent geht, vom Markt verschwindet?
Gibt es da irgendwas mit muss open source, bla bla bla, Dokumentation muss veröffentlicht
werden, da ist nichts drin?
Das wäre super gut. Ich kann die Frage leider nicht beantworten.
So im Detail habe ich es mir jetzt vor der Sendung nicht angeschaut.
Wir haben auch bei dem Gesetz nur an zwei, drei Punkten mitgewirkt und die finale
Fassung habe ich gar nicht gelesen.
Ich habe so die Medienberichte und FAQs gelesen, da stand dazu nichts drinnen,
aber ich finde das Thema super wichtig, vielleicht kennt sich Linus da ja auch,
das ist ja auch in seinem Brotberuf wichtig,
was da drin steht und hoffentlich hat er da auch eine Meinung,
aber ich glaube für viele Leute, die uns hören, könnte das auch einen Blick wert sein.
Alright, dann sind wir ja schon fast durch.
Jetzt müssen wir noch ein bisschen Veranstaltungsankündigungen betreiben, denn ist ja bald 38 C3.
Ihr wisst, das ist immer ein Thema, was uns hier sehr betrifft,
weil wir da immer alle abhängen und weil das ja sozusagen auch einfach so ein
bisschen die Party des Jahres ist und diesmal auch wieder gut besucht sein wird.
Wie man dem hohen Druck auf Ticketnachfrage entnehmen kann.
Also die Veranstaltung ist auf jeden Fall ausverkauft.
Wenn ihr dabei seid, toll. Wenn ihr nicht dabei sein könnt, habt ihr natürlich
die Möglichkeit, alles auch,
also nicht alles, aber halt die Vorträge online zu verfolgen,
weil das Allermeiste wird natürlich live gestreamt gestreamt und auch zeitnah veröffentlicht.
Und genau, wir machen kurz einen Blick auf den Fahrplan vielleicht mal,
weil du natürlich und wie auch Linus, ich wiederum nicht im Programm vertreten seid.
Und erzähl doch mal ein bisschen, was du da vorhast. Dein erster Vortrag heißt
EU's Digital Identity Systems Reality Check and Techniques for Better Privacy.
Genau.
Machst du auch nicht alleine, sondern machst du zusammen mit Anja Lehmann,
die Kryptografin ist am HPI.
Genau, ich glaube, die hast du eh auch gestern kennengelernt.
Anja ist sehr geniale Kryptografin und sie ist auch in der Jury von Sprint gemeinsam
mit mir und arbeitet sehr viel mit diesem ganzen Zero-Knowledge-Thema.
Und ist da eine der treibenden Kräfte, dass wir das bekommen und dass das auch Realität wird.
Und Ziel von dem Vortrag ist, einen Reality-Check zu machen.
Also was steht in dem EI das Gesetz und was wird dann wirklich auch in der technischen
Realität sich abspielen?
Wo gibt es da Probleme? Und das sind einige, über die wir da reden werden.
Das Ganze ist an Tag 1, wir am Abend, wir verlinken eh die genauen Zeiten.
Und ich darf dann mithelfen und sozusagen Anja gibt uns den Reality-Check.
Dann bin ich auch kurz auf der Bühne bei dem Thema Netzeutralität.
Da habe ich das letzte Mal schon gemunkelt.
Wir haben da was vor. Und gemeinsam mit Jürgen Behring von der GFF und Raquel
Renon-Nunes von Article 19 reden wir über Net Neutrality and why it still matters more than ever.
Geht es auch um globale Perspektiven und wie Zero Rating Fake News begünstigt
und was wir in Europa noch planen.
Dazu wird es auch einen Workshop geben.
Der dann am Tag 4 laufen wird. Wie gesagt, Ort und Zeit verschiebt sich vielleicht
noch, aber wir verlinken.
Linus hat einen Vortrag mit dem genialen Titel Der Thüring-Test für Wahlsoftware, gemeinsam mit DHS.
Ja, der sehe ich gut. Wir lesen aus der Beschreibung. Vor der Bundestagswahl
2017 veröffentlichten wir unsere Analyse über haarsträubende Sicherheitslücken
in einer weit verbreiteten Wahlsoftware.
Seitdem ist einiges passiert. Der Hersteller hat die Probleme nicht behoben.
Das BSI hat einen Stapel Papier produziert.
Die deutschen Anbieter von Wahlsoftware haben ihr Kartell vergrößert und unterschiedliche
Wahlpannen untergraben weiterhin das Vertrauen in die Demokratie.
Wurden unsere Empfehlungen von 2017 umgesetzt. Wir nehmen den Dekompiler und schauen mal nach.
Tja, Spannung, Cliffhanger.
Ja, Linus und THS. Achso, vielleicht sollten wir auch mal sagen,
wann das ist. das ist hier am Abend des ersten Tages Hauptabendprogramm.
Wenn man da rein will, besser früher schon.
Ja, schon drei Vorträge vorher mal einen Platz suchen.
Genau, und du bist auch am Tag eins, ach ja, parallel dazu, ne?
Leute, ihr seid gleichzeitig.
Super.
Dann müsst ihr euch entscheiden, Thomas oder Linus. Wenn bei Thomas kein Platz
mehr ist, dann könnt ihr jetzt zu Linus gehen.
Und am dritten Tag seid ihr mit dem Netzneutralität-Thema am Start,
Oh, um null, was? Um null, oh, 55. Ja, das war der Rest.
Alter.
Ja, Netzentralität, das Randthema.
Oh Gott, die, oh Mann ey, da wurden noch früher Filme gezeigt.
Naja, okay, gut, also das Programm ist voll.
Nerds sind nachtaktiv.
Ja, ja, ich weiß nicht, das funktioniert trotzdem.
Was haben wir sonst noch in dem Programm? Und wir haben jetzt keinen Anspruch
auf Vollständigkeit, wir haben wirklich nur so ein paar Perlen ausgerufen.
Und bitte macht euch selber euer Bild, was den Fahrplan betrifft.
Aber es gibt auch noch einen Vortrag, auf den ich mich freue.
Escaping Big Brother or Your Ex?
Counter Surveillance for Women's Shelters von Erlan.
Das Thema Stalkerware ist ja ein riesiges, also eigentlich Staatstrojaner auf
den Telefonen von PartnerInnen und eben so Überwachung in Beziehungen ist leider
bei Frauenhäusern ein riesiges Thema geworden. Da muss man hinschauen.
Worauf ich mich auch freue ist von Elenos ein unmoralisches Angebot,
wie wir unsere Communities vor ideologischen Zugriffen schützen Elenos.
Dieses Albtraum Logbuch Netzpolitik 500 ja.
Ja, ja also die Frau kann singen und jodeln und reden ja, Philosophin und bei
dem Vortrag freue ich mich drauf,
Konstanze Kurz und Friederike Hildebrandt werden über klimaschädlich bei Design
sprechen, die ökologischen Kosten des KI-Hypes. Ganz wichtiges Thema.
Johannes Fertmann spricht über brauchbare
Illegalität, Organisationen für menschenfeindliche Diskurse, Wattmann.
Also da geht es auch um, wie geht man um im Sportverein mit...
AfDs, mit rechtsextremen Trends in der Gesellschaft, wie wappen da,
wie kann man da seine eigenen Vereine, Organisationen oder den Teil der Gesellschaft,
wo man aktiv ist, wo man ist, wappnen vor solchen Trends.
Besonders mutig finde ich den Vortrag von einer Freundin von mir,
die selber aus einem ostafrikanischen Land kommt und über LGBT-Situation dort spricht.
Roleplay as Resistance, Challenging Securitization through Activism in a Place in East Africa.
Große Empfehlung. Und ganz zuletzt haben wir noch einen sehr lustigen Vortrag
und zwar, was macht ein IT-Systemadministrator in einem Aluschmelzwerk?
Das wird Johannes Bernstein vortragen und ich glaube, der wird sehr lustig.
Insgesamt, die wichtigste Information ist eigentlich heute noch am besten,
dass ihr euch Merch sichern solltet.
Noch gibt es einen Vorverkauf für Merchandise und wenn ihr coole Hoodies,
coole T-Shirts haben wollt, dann solltet ihr die jetzt dann noch im Vorfeld sichern.
Die werden dann vor Ort verkauft, also vor Ort ausgegeben, bezahlen müsst ihr sie im Vorfeld schon.
Aber bei dem Merch ist es halt eine Abgabe vor Ort also ihr braucht ein Ticket
für die Veranstaltung das wird nicht verschickt, sondern kann vor Ort abgeholt
werden, aber es wird on demand produziert,
das heißt wenn ihr T-Shirts oder anderen Merch haben wollt, dann bitte im Vorfeld jetzt noch klicken,
solange das geht und dann, ich glaube bis zum 28.
Dezember 22 Uhr können dann diese Items abgeholt werden am Kongress vor Ort Vielen Dank.
Wenn ihr euch zurechtfinden wollt, gibt es das tolle System C3NAV.
Da sind Karten von mehr oder weniger allem an Orten, was ihr am Kongress suchen
könntet, vorhanden und auch Navigation, das ist super hilfreich,
wenn man sich auch mit Leuten dort treffen will.
Auch die vielen NGOs, die vor Ort sind, kann man dort suchen und wir werden
auch einen Infostand aus Epicenter Works haben im Rahmen des Habitat Clusters,
wo ganz, ganz viele NGOs anzutreffen sind.
Also wenn ihr euch netzpolitisch austauschen wollt, da habt ihr wahrscheinlich
die höchste Dichte an Vereinen, auch von anderen Themenfeldern,
wie zum Beispiel Kados und Sea-Watch werden dort sein,
Korrektiv wird vor Ort sein.
Also da gibt es ganz viele spannende Leute anzutreffen und das ist dann so im
Garderobenfoyer, also wenn man reinkommt bei einem Event, einfach die erste
Rolltreppe in diesen Zwischenstock hoch,
da wird es diesmal auch mehr Sofa-Ecken geben, ist vielleicht auch ein guter Ort zum Verweilen.
Und zuletzt wird es natürlich auch Workshops und Self-Organized Sessions und
Community-Bühnen geben.
Dafür ist auch Programm, und zwar ein sehr fettes Programm, vorgesehen.
Also da sind viele Sachen, die werden nicht geschrieben. Die kann man also im
Nachhinein nicht nachschauen.
Das ist vielleicht auch was wert,
weil das sind dann direkte 101-Diskussionen, die man dort haben kann.
Da wird es auch freie Software geben, die vorgestellt wird.
Und ganz viele interessante Debatten, ich meine die gibt es sowieso überall
dort, auch im T-Tent, im obersten Stochwerk ist meistens so ein guter Ort für Diskussionen.
Ja, also es ist unmöglich, alles mitzubekommen, was am Kongress passiert.
Es sind wie viel? 14.000 Leute, die dort sein werden und ganz viel Programm,
ganz viele spannende Sachen.
Versucht nicht, overwhelmed zu sein. Haltet euch an die 6-2-1-Regel.
Sechs Stunden schlafen, zweimal essen, einmal duschen pro Tag.
Und ihr werdet gut durch das Programm kommen.
Nicht insgesamt, nein.
Ja, ich muss auch noch man könnte es jetzt ewig noch fortführen,
aber einen Talk muss man natürlich auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen, Jean Peters,
der ja auch bei LNP zu Gast war wird quasi diese Korrektivrecherche Geheimplan
gegen Deutschland ein Jahr danach vorstellen,
Das nehmen wir auch alles noch mit in die Shownotes und ja Arne.
Wird auch Arne.
Semsrott hat natürlich auch einen Vortrag.
Das IFG ist tot. Verlinken wir auch nochmal.
Best auf Informationsfreiheit, Gefahr der Befreiung und Machtübernahme.
Arne hat ja auch ein neues Buch geschrieben, was schon hier Thema war.
Ja, was er hier auch schon vorgestellt hat, da sind wir ganz mit der Zeit.
Wir könnten die Liste jetzt noch ewig fortsetzen, schaut einfach mal selber
in den Fahrplan rein und wenn ihr sozusagen nicht da seid und eh nur irgendwie
gelangweilt bei euren Eltern rumsitzt,
dann könnt ihr auch einfach ein bisschen Stream gucken, das ist auch ganz gut.
Man kann ja auch live teilnehmen, also es gibt immer so Online-Chat-Möglichkeiten,
man kann dann quasi auch von außen Fragen stellen,
das wissen viele nicht, also man kann quasi selber ins Mikrofon gehen und dann
auch live Fragen einbringen.
Wie heißt das so schön, das heißt dann der?
Signal Ains.
Genau, der trägt das dann sozusagen im Saal für euch vor.
Und, und, und, und, und. Und außerdem gibt es auch noch das Sendezentrum,
das muss ich jetzt hier auch nochmal erwägen.
Wir waren ja letztes Jahr schon wieder an einem neuen Stelle da,
also Sendezentrum, die Podcast-Community, wer also Lust hat,
Leute aus dem Podcasting-Bereich zu treffen,
da hängen die eigentlich immer alle rum.
Und wir haben dieses Jahr auch auf derselben Ebene einen eigenen Vortragsraum.
Also Vortragsraum ist kein Vortragsraum im Sinne von wie die anderen Vorträge,
sondern wir haben dort einen Raum,
da gibt es eine Bühne und dort werden verschiedene Sachen stattfinden.
Tagsüber wird dort der Deutschlandfunk ein paar Sendungen produzieren,
teilweise mit Publikum.
Wir werden dann so irgendwann einen Nachmittag, frühen Abend übernehmen und
dann wird es halt Live-Podcasts Podcasts geben.
Ihr könnt, wenn ihr auf dem Kongressseiten dort einen Podcast live aufnehmen
wollt, on stage, könnt ihr das einreichen.
Wenn ihr einen podcastbezogenen Workshop oder einen Kurzvortrag oder sowas halten
wollt, also wo es konkret um Podcasting geht, nicht irgendwas zu irgendeinem
Thema, sondern das ist unser Fokus, ja, Audio-Technik,
Podcasting, was auch immer,
dann solltet ihr das in unseren CFP einwerfen, Link ist auch in den Shownotes.
Kurz beschreiben, was ihr wollt etc.
Ich weiß, es ist kurzfristig, aber da ist auf jeden Fall jetzt auch noch Platz zu haben.
Wer keinen Bock hat, auf einer Bühne zu sitzen mit Publikum,
also es ist nicht riesig, wir haben da was weiß ich, 50, 60 Plätze maximal,
glaube ich, irgendwas in der Größenordnung, vielleicht auch 80 Plätze.
Aber wir haben dann vorne, also der Raum ist dann so ein bisschen weiter hinten
und vorne, wo wir sitzen,
haben wir dann aber auch noch den Podcast-Tisch, da kann man irgendwie gemütlich
am Tisch rumsitzen und mit vier, fünf Leuten da aufnehmen, da kann man dann
auch zuhören, dann werden wir so Kopfhörer haben,
das heißt, wenn da jemand am Podcast-Tisch podcastet, kann man sich einfach
dazusetzen, Kopfhörer aufsetzen, zuhören,
das ist auch noch mit dabei und ansonsten sind wir da einfach vor Ort ansprechbar.
Wuseln rum und ja, das ist sozusagen.
Da kann man dann hingehen und schauen, ob man die Leute an der Stimme erkennt.
Ja, genau. Das kann man da machen. Oder wenn man halt einfach Fragen hat und
Interesse hat, werden auch einige vom Potlav Team vor Ort sein.
Wir arbeiten auch an ein paar neuen Sachen und so weiter.
Also da ist auf jeden Fall jetzt wieder ein bisschen Musik in der ganzen Geschichte
und wir freuen uns natürlich sehr, wenn ihr vorkommt.
Wir sind in im Bereich X. Vormals Twitter.
Und das Habitat von Bits und Bäume und About Freedom ist so in diesem Garderobenfoyer ist das.
Da wo wir früher waren.
Genau. Und ihr erkennt uns alle an unseren Radiogesichten. Genau.
Oder an der Stimme.
Ja.
Super.
Okay, Thomas. Das war doch nett. Jetzt sind wir, glaube ich,
am Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Ja, ich freue mich total auf den Kongress und war schön, dabei zu sein und allen schönen Feiertage.
Genau. Und wir hören uns aber auch noch mal vor dem Kongress und dann sehen
wir uns auf dem Kongress oder falls ihr nicht da seid.
Danach hören wir uns danach wieder. Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.